- It's nice to meet you.
- So nice to meet you.
- That was hilarious,
the clip
- Oh good!
- Is this just such a
fun cast to work with?
- It's so much fun, yeah, it's crazy.
I have to pinch myself all
the time 'cause I'm like,
- Oh my God.
- it feels like TV royalty
that I get to work with.
- Yeah and I feel like you just laugh
on set probably all day long.
- Yeah, all the time.
- Yeah.
- I am always
the first person to break too.
I'm always like I, keep it together.
- Oh my gosh, I'm not good at that.
I had to do SNL
- Yeah, no.
- and I was like, how am I
supposed to not laugh right now?
That's the whole point
- yeah, like this is weird,
- like they're trying to make you laugh.
- Yeah.
- I was like this is hard.
- This is funny I'm gonna laugh.
- Yes.